History looping through your cold machines, warm, where humming's your soft set, get carried through the tangled wires, cold machines, warm ghosts, you sing, and something in me shakes, I'm holding on to where. Hi guys, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and thank you for listening to Part 3 of Psychotherapy on the Couch, a Psycho History of American Psychology. What psychology can see, what it can't see, and why it has trouble telling the difference. In my opinion, the other half of the revolution, the half of women's liberation movement,
is the boys in my country and in yours wearing their hair long. And those boys who are wearing their hair long are saying, No to the masculine mystique. They are saying no to that brutal, sadistic, tight-lipped, crew-cut, you know, Prussian, big muscle, you know, Ernest Hemingway, kill bears when there are no bears to kill, and napalm all the children in Vietnam and Cambodia to prove that I'm a man, you know,
and be dominant and superior to everyone concerned, and never show any softness. Well, these boys that are wearing their hair long are saying, no. I don't have to be all that crew cut and tight lip. I don't have to be dominant and superior to anyone. I don't have to have big muscles
because there aren't any bears to kill. I don't have to, you know, kill anybody to prove anything. I can be tender and I can be sensitive and I can be compassionate and I can admit sometimes that I'm afraid and I can even cry. And I am a man. I am my own. I am my own.
man and that man who is strong enough to be geno, that is a new man, and he is the other half of this revolution. In 1963, Betty Friedan published the feminine mystique and gave name to something that had been floating through American consciousness for nearly two decades. She called it the problem that has no name. And Friedan was writing about suburban housewives, women who had everything that the culture told them that they should want, husbands, children, modern homes filled with labor-saving appliances.
and these women should have been happy. But the magazines told them that they were happy. The advertisements showed them smiling, and yet in interview after interview, Bradan found something else entirely. A vague and persistent dissatisfaction, an on way, a sense that something was missing,
a feeling that there must be more to life than this. And the housewives were not the only ones feeling it. Their husbands commuting to corporate jobs, climbing ladders whose tops they could never quite see, felt it too. And so did their children, The baby boomers, growing up in communities that were physically comfortable and psychologically sterile.
And so did the artists, writers, and intellectuals watching American culture become increasingly homogenized, increasingly optimized, and increasingly empty. This was a strange achievement of post-war America. Unprecedented material abundance, coexisting with unprecedented spiritual vacancy. And the nation had won the war, built the suburbs, filled the garages with automobiles, and the kitchens with appliances, the economy was booming, and the middle class was expanding. and yet something was wrong and something was missing. This episode is about that void and the various attempts to fill it.
It is about what psychology did during the three decades of American Triumph and what it failed to do. It's about the genuine seekers who tried to find alternatives to the emptiness, and a couple hucksters along the way, against the machinery that absorbed their seeking and sold it back to them as a lifestyle, and it's about the modalities that emerged, the theories that competed, and the fundamental question that nobody wanted to answer. What happens when human beings are given everything except? meaning. To understand the psychological condition of post-war America, you have to understand what
was actually built and why. Between 1945 and 1960, the physical landscape of American life was transformed more rapidly and thoroughly than at any point in the nation's history before. 16 million veterans returned from the war. And while the nation was ostensibly grateful for their service, the political and economic establishment was absolutely terrified of their reintegration. The memory of the Great Depression was fresh. The last thing that anyone wanted was 16 million unemployed young men flooding back into the labor market and potentially sparking a European-style communist revolution right here at home. But beneath this, fear lay an even darker and more unspeakable realization.
As Noam Chomsky pointed out, it was not Franklin Delano Roosevelt's New Deal that got America out of the Great Depression. The new deal looked like it might have been working, but the experiment was never really run. How could we ever truly tell if it hadn't been the war? because what broke the back of the economic terror was the massive blood-soaked industrial engine of World War II and the total war manufacturing capacity that America had adopted in order to fight the war. And this created a terrifying shadow that still haunts America to this day. The underlying and unspoken realization that the American economic machine might actually need an existential threat to survive, and that when it doesn't have one, it might seek to manufacture one.
It might require the conditions of total war to maintain a functioning economy, and perhaps we were only able to exist in opposition to an enemy. And so we simulated the conditions of total war for most of the rest of our existence. We needed the Cold War and we needed the myth of the Soviet threat to justify the terrifying machinery of the new military industrial complex, to keep the factories open and to quiet our own psychological ghosts. And this was a massive tragic hinge point in American history. When the war ended, we had a choice. We had the economic surplus and the technological power to completely revision the American dream.
We could have built a society where meaning was derived from specialized craft, from deep organic community, or from a shared civic purpose. And instead, we defined the American dream as a suburban home, a perfectly manicured square of grass, the ability to eat eight servings of red meat a day, and the ability to buy everything that you needed without ever having to produce anything yourself. We hollowed out the core of human experience,
and because this new dream contained largely no meaning, we replaced the soul with the myth of normal. a baseline of acceptable consumption that we would be forced to frantically reinvent every 10 years just to keep the economic engine running. The suburbs themselves were a product of this paranoia. The GI Bill and the Federal Highway Act of 1956, officially titled the National System of Interstate and Defense Highways, poured billions into creating this new reality. It wasn't just a consumer utopia, it was an explicitly military strategy.
And dense urban centers were nuclear targets. A single Soviet bomb could eliminate millions of workers. crippling American industrial capacity. The solution was dispersal, spread the population outward, in a low-density suburb connected by highways that could serve as evacuation routes. The animization of the American family was literal, state-sponsored nuclear defense. The houses were nearly identical, Cape Cod-style 750 square feet in a patch of grass, and while they offered central heating and indoor plumbing, they aggressively eradicated public space. There were no town squares. There were no walkable commercial districts. As the philosopher Hanna Arendt noted,
public space is the essential theater of human appearance, the realm where political action and true community occur. The suburb aggressively eradicated this space, and later theorists of new urbanism, like friend of the podcast, Leon Creer, would correctly identify this spatial segregation as an architectural pathology, a deliberate severing of civic life that isolated the individual within a private domestic form. Well, it's sort of a stupid job, really. There's nothing interesting about it at all. What do you do it for, then? Maybe Frank doesn't like being questioned by this. Oh, okay, okay, okay, I know. It's none of my business. And besides, I know the answer. You want to play a house, you've got to have a job. You want to play a very nice house, very sweet house.
Then you've got to have a job you don't like. Anyone comes along and says, what do you do it for? He's probably on a... Four hour pass from the state funny farm. This was a society that was drunk on the illusion of absolute engineering. They had split the atom. They were aiming rockets at the moon. And the American domestic space was rapidly being flooding with a techno fix. The automatic washing machine, the television set, and eventually the microwave oven.
The prevailing cultural ideology was that the human struggle was obsolete. Any problem no matter how complex or emotional could be solved with the push of a button. The atomic bomb did not just split the atom. It split the timeline of human consciousness. For the entirety of human history, despite plagues and wars, there was always an underlying assumption of continuity. There would always be a tomorrow, and suddenly for the first time, humanity possessed the technology to instantly delete itself and started living only for the future.
The looming shadow of the bomb effectively broke traditional psychoanalysis. The Freudian model required time. It required years on the couch, patiently excavating early childhood memories to slowly, methodically construct a stable future. But how do you sell the promise of a stable future to a generation of children doing duck and cover drills? What else is that psychoanalysis's large appeal had always been that it let you peel back the layers and stare at this big sexy secret beneath the world,
that people were monsters on autopilot that were not in control of the forces that made them run their life? When you're looking at an atomic error and you've just finished a world war, being able to look at the secret horror of humanity had sort of lost its sexiness and its appeal. People wanted a technique, and they also wanted to get rid of the anxiety that they were now feeling, not to dabble in psychological horror
as much as they had wanted to in the avoidant era of the 1920s. Mr. Draper, you sound hostile. After hundreds of dollars, all you've managed to do is make her more unhappy. I understand this is frustrating for you. This has nothing to do with me. It's her. You took a woman with a bad case of nerves, and you made her weaker, not stronger. All I can say is that it's a process, and time is part of it.
If you'd like to expedite things, we can put her in psychoanalysis. What are you doing now? Psychoanalytic psychotherapy. Psychoanalysis would mean a minimum of three sessions a week and optimally five. Thank you. I'll think about that. The prevailing models of psychotherapy had inherited a massive cultural mandate, but they were ill-equipped to handle their own shadow.
And even today, if you look closely at the psychological establishment, it is suffering from the same unresolved identity crisis that developed at this time. What is psychotherapy? Is it a branch of the philosophy department exploring the uncomputable depths of the human soul? Is it the search for consciousness or religion? Is it a branch of the pharmaceutical agency, a biological mechanism for adjusting neurochemistry? Is it a branch of the biomedical model, functioning under the rigid hierarchy of the hospital? Or is it just people who like to study humans? that we allow to operate in the space so that hopefully they glean some interesting information. The providers themselves don't agree.
They constantly fight among themselves, drawing ideological lines in the sand based on their own perspectives. And beneath all the end fighting is a deep paralyzing insecurity. Because psychotherapy deals with the subjective invisible realm of human suffering, it constantly feels insecure that it doesn't have a serious objective legitimacy of a hard science, like physics or surgery. So whenever psychology feels threatened, it adopts the aesthetics of hard science to be. protect itself. And in the 1950s, the aesthetics it chose was the push-button machinery of the techno fix.
All right, hold on. Just hold on. I'll call the doctor. Calling Dr. Racy. Dr. Ken Racy. Yes, Mrs. Jetson. In 1955, Wallace Laboratory is released a drug called Meprobomate, marketed under the friendly name, Milltown. And it became the first blockbuster mass market psychotropic drug in American history. Miltown was explicitly marketed as a peace pill for homemakers. It functioned as a central nervous depressant, essentially a muscle relaxant that dulled the brain's emotional receptors. And it did not alter the crushing atomized isolation of the suburban housewife, but it did
muffle the panic, the dread, and the profound structural despair. And this is where the psychopharmacology industry realized that they had stumbled upon the greatest gold mine in the history of medicine. The executives realized that if they aggressively allied themselves with the military's myth of normal. They could profit off of it forever because the statistical normal was a mathematical abstraction. It was functionally impossible for a real human being to achieve it. What was Miletown treating? Officially it treated anxiety, but the anxiety it treated was often the appropriate response of healthy organisms without agency, and the women taking Miltown were not broken. They were trapped, and the drug did not fix the trap. It made it tolerable. The pattern would repeat with value,
introduced in 1963, which became known as Mother's Little Helper after the Rolling Stone song. Valium was even more successful than Milltown, and by 1978, 2.3 billion tablets were being sold annually. America had become a nation that required mass sedation to function, and the psychiatric establishment largely accepted this arrangement. The medication worked, in the sense that they reduced symptoms. It gave psychiatry a quick and easy fix in order to justify itself as a profession, and patients reported feeling better. They were often able to continue functioning in their roles as housewives, as mothers, as consumers. The facts that the symptoms were often signals of other latent suffering were ignored. There were warnings from the organism that something was wrong and systemically ignored.
And so while mainstream biomedical psychology had consigned itself to the role of engine technician doing monthly oil changes for routine maintenance, the fringes were changing metaphors of what. human agency and consciousness was at this time with the sciences of California. A pivotal moment occurred at a series of conferences that almost nobody outside specialist circles had ever heard of, the Macy conferences on cybernetics. Help between 1946 and 1953, these gatherings brought together mathematicians, engineers, biologists, and social scientists to discuss a new way of thinking about systems, cybernetics.
The same difficulty applies to all mathematics. If you could define the relationships exactly before you set out and then translate them into mathematical symbols, the mathematics would work perfectly. But it is in choosing those relationships and defining them that we have the problem. Nevertheless, we are going to have to understand ever more complex systems if we are to deal with the future.
Without their understanding, there may be no future. Earlier in the program, we heard how Vena first developed his feedback concept when he was trying to help anti-aircraft gunners to hit enemy planes. Here, we have a video game which simulates the shooting down of spacecraft. Let's play that game. The term was coined by Norbert Wiener. Cyrenetics was the study of control and communications in animals, machines. Its central insight was that both living organisms and mechanical devices could be
understood through the same concepts, feedback loops, information processing, and homeostatic regulation. At the same conferences, Claude Shannon was presenting his mathematical theory of information. When Shannon showed that information could be quantified, measured in bits, transmitted through channels, the mind was no longer a steam engine. Now it was a program. The cognitive revolution that would transform psychology in the 1960s and 1970s was built on cybernetic foundations. Thoughts became programs, and memories became data stored in biological hardware. Mental illness became bugs in the software. And when you think of the mind as a computer, certain questions become natural and others become invisible.
You ask about processing speed. You don't ask about meaning, purpose, or the lived experience of being conscious. Those questions don't compute. The cybernetic revolution reinforced the individual. tendency of American psychology. A computer does not exist in relationship. It does not have a community. It needs only to function correctly. And if mental illness is a software bug, then treatment is debugging, and the therapeutic relationship becomes irrelevant. What matters is the technique. The most heavily funded ideological currents of the time were mathematicians, economists, and strategists
that had been brought together largely through the RAND Corporation, funded by the US DOD and the Air Force, to think about the unthinkable, nuclear war. The answer that these think tanks developed was game theory, a mathematical framework for analyzing strategic interaction. Game theory treated human beings as rational actors, who calculated costs and benefits and chose strategies to increase reward and decrease punishment. A profound internal ideological division existed at the brand
regarding the psychology of warfare. The mathematics analytics division, Mad, relied heavily on the technostratic language. a sanitized hyper-rational vocabulary that deliberately stripped the emotional and moral weight from the concept of nuclear annihilation. In these quantitative war game simulations, players were reduced to the logic of an analog computer, frequently escalating nuclear launches without hesitation. In stark contrast, the Social Sciences Division, or SSD, designed games with high narrative realism, engaging emotional intelligence, resulting in marked nuclear restraint. And this proved early on that deliberate abstraction of language effectively overrides human barriers against mass violence.
But over time, the same insecurity that affects psychology and large institutions, the pivot towards hard sciences in times of crisis or in times of institutional insecurity or uncertainty, affected the DoD. The mathematical model began to shape the reality that it described. If you design institutions assuming that people are strategic calculators, you create incentives. you create incentives that reward strategic calculation. And eventually, people learn to think of themselves as strategic calculators. The war for the metaphor was over.
And in 1964, a psychiatrist named Eric Byrne published a book that would introduce game theoretic thinking to the American middle class. The Games People Play is a book we've talked about on an earlier series that this podcast put out. It was a popular psychology book filled with catchy names for the patterns that Byrne had observed in his patients and relationships. Burn defined a game as a reoccurring pattern of interaction with a hidden psychological payoff. The book effectively effused game theory coming out of the DoD with the language of psychoanalysis, and it fit the zeitgeist perfectly. In the suburbs where organic community had been replaced by competitive consumption,
relationships really did feel like games. Transactual and analysis was a meteoric hit. As the cybernetic view of the mind combined with this game theoretic view of strategy, A sociologist named Irvin Goffman captured the exact psychological mechanism of the post-war era. In his book, The Presentation of Self in Everyday Life, Goffman argued that human beings are essentially actors on a stage. We are constantly engaged in impression management. There is a front stage where we perform the happy suburban life, the perfect marriage, the successful career, and there is the backstage where we drop the mask, exhausted by the performance.
In Gothman's theory implied that there was no true authentic self at all. just a series of calculated masks worn to navigate a hollow society. And when you combine the cybernetic view of the mind as a computer with the Goffman's sociological view of the self as a performer, you get a society of isolated notes, frantically managing their image to survive in the suburbs. And this performative machine is vitally important to understand, because it explains the psychology of the baby boomers. The boomers refused to look down.
They refuse to question certain structural truths that they knew were operating behind. the scenes deep down and they knew that these suburbs were essentially built like Western movie sets Hollywood facades playing at permanence they knew that the community was an illusion but to admit that the set was fake would require abandoning the safety of the performance and this is exactly why their children would later you know Generation X and Millennials react so violently through ultimately unsuccessfully to picking another vision that could pull the culture in another direction they could see the cracks in the Western town facades
and their parents had agreed to politely ignore them. Adam Smith needs revision. What are you talking about? If we all go for the blonde, we block each other. Not a single one of us is going to get her. So then we go for her friends. But they will all give us the cold shoulder because nobody likes to be second choice.
What if no one goes for the blonde? We don't get in each other's way. And we don't insult the other girls. That's the only way we win. That's the only way we all get late. Adam Smith said the best result comes from everyone in the group doing what's best for himself, right? That's what he said, is that right?
Incomplete, incomplete. Okay? Because the best result would come from everyone in the group doing what's best for himself and the group. Ash, this is some way for you to get the blonde on your own. You can go to hell. Governing and down average, gentlemen.
Governing dynamics. Adam Smith. The human potential movement emerged as a response to the crisis of the coldness of this new conception of humanity. At its epicenter was the Eastland Institute founded in 1962 on the spectacular cliffs of Big Sur, California. Eastland was not a single thing. It was a space where many different approaches converged, collided, and cross-pollinated. Humanistic psychologists like Abraham Maslow brought their theories of self-actualization. Fritz Perils brought Gestral- Therapy. with its emphasis on present moment awareness, emotional expression,
and its experiential nature that would later be fused with Jung's theories to create parts-based therapies like internal family systems. Alexander Lowen brought bio-energetic analysis, a body-based approach descended from Wilhelm Reich. Alan Watts brought Zen Buddhism and Eastern philosophy, and Ida Rolf brought structural integration, manipulating the body's connective tissue to release chronic tension. I'd like to buy the world a home and furnish it with love.
Grow apple trees and honeybees and so white turtle does. I like to teach the world to sing with me. What these approaches shared was a rejection of the dominant psychological paradigm. They rejected the Freudian emphasis on pathology, on uncovering childhood trauma, on the analysts as an authority figure, and they rejected the behavioralist denier of inner experience, and they rejected the medical model that treated psychological distress as a disease to be eliminated rather than a signal to be understood,
and they rejected a cyber genetic vision of the mind as a person as a computer, with inputs and outputs that was all that they are. Instead, they proposed that human beings have vast untapped potential for growth, creativity and transcendence that could lead us into the next era. Then this overlapped with the New Age movement's obsession with Aquarius and moving into a new age of consciousness. And the cross-pollination was pretty extreme. The goal of psychological work was not adjusting to society,
but self-actualization, becoming more fully who you were and more capable of being. The body was not an inconvenient container for the mind, but a source of wisdom, a locus of blocked energy that could be released. and Eastern spiritual practices offered technologies of consciousness that Western psychology had ignored. This was in many ways a recovery of what William James had proposed decades earlier, and a return to psychoanalysts like Carl Jung. It was a return to the stream of consciousness, to radical empiricism, and to the insistence that the subjective experience mattered, that the transcendent life was real, that the inner life was real, and that the measurable was not the only way to measure.
The encounter group became the signature practice of the movement. The final episode of the show Mad Men, it's heavily implied that Don is at an encounter group in Eastland, if you've seen that show. And an encounter group participants gathered to practice radical honesty, expressing their feelings openly and receiving feedback from others. And the rules of normal social interaction were suspended. You were encouraged to say what you actually felt,
even when it was ugly, even if it violated politely. authenticity was prized over performance. And for many participants, these experiences were genuinely transformative. They reported moments of connection, breakthrough, catharsis, that they had never experienced in ordinary life or in conventional therapy. And something was real that was happening in those rooms, but it couldn't be measured, not as a mechanism of action, and also not as a result of therapy. It was something that was a truth that was self-evident, beyond the numbers. But we must clear a common misunderstanding. The human potential movement and cybernetics were not entirely opposed.
In reality, they were deeply entwined. They were both major currents that intellectuals and thinkers saw as the forefront of the discoveries of their era. Early tech pioneers and cyberneticists were frequent visitors at Eekyllen, and the translation of cybernetics into a tool for personal liberation was largely brokered by Stuart Brand, though through the creation of the whole earth catalog. Operating near elite engineering teams, Brand and his collaborators viewed small-scale technologies and information networks as mechanisms to undermine bureaucracies and empower the individual. The whole Earth catalog functioned as a Bible of counterculture technology. Anthropologists and cyberneticians like Gregory Bateson deeply influenced both Brand and Eastland. They argue that the
mind and the environment were part of a single co-evolving information system. As a result, the countercultural quest to find oneself became inextricably linked to the engineering imperative to optimize oneself. The computer metaphor wasn't just forced on us by the military. We embraced it in our search for liberation. Finally, the inner world had become a product and something that could affect the outer material world, not just a naval gazing inner point of subjective experience, but something that could help you help others if you helped yourself. The true power of the human petitional movement was because of some of the characters operating in it. There were people who genuinely misunderstood psychology and people who fundamentally misunderstood
how America works. The movement became a chaotic collision of competing archetypes. There were corporate grifters, you know, figures like some of the people involved in early NLP, who were very high on cocaine and packaging fragments of psychological insight due to their, you know, intelligence in order to weaponize them into something that they could sell quickly to a corporation. Some of these people were narcissists who genuinely thought that they were God and others simply just didn't care if you mistook them for him. And second, there were these naive idealists. And these were the well-meaning therapist who believed that if America simply invented a kumbaya loving, caring, perfect psychology, the traumatized masses would line up begging to be cured.
And this was a profound misunderstanding of the American psyche, which is always valued rugged individualism and productivity over vulnerability. They thought that love alone could dismantle this military industrial complex and that eventually if you ordered organic seeds and meditated, things in the exterior world were changed. There was also a lot of New Age Hocum. This was this friend that believed in laylines and magic crystals would one day supplant the microchip through the inevitability of magic being better than science. Con artists who spoke the language of the New Age movement and cybernetics in order to scam people, like the Beatles, the Magic Alex guy that sold them the like
10,000 million point one surround sound studio or whatever. You know, these pioneers in trauma and semantic psychology were doing incredible work. They were finally beginning to understand how trauma lives in the nervous system in the midst of all of these waters with some of the better therapy that the country had ever done. You know, they were learning how the body held attention. And they were seeing how when you put all of these different fields
that were getting at something real but hard to measure in the same spot, big Venn diagrams and overlaps came. Many of the new models of psychotherapy, the third and fourth wave models, have roots in this era, and would have been inevitable without this fusion in Eastland. Therapists like Peter Levin were sort of a successor to people like Wilhelm Reich, based on a couple levels of influence in between them. But because of the noise, it's crucial to understand that the human potential movement
and the broader counterculture of which it was a part did not really end in a counterculture. It was a counter aesthetic. The distinction is important here because a counterculture could have challenged the fundamental structures that were producing the void that America was feeling. The economic arrangements,
the spatial organization, the institutional incentives that atomized individuals and reduced relationships to transactions. A counterculture would have built alternative institutions created different ways of organizing, creating family and community,
and established, you know, enduring structures that embodied different values. That didn't happen. What actually emerged was a counter-aesthetic, a set of styles, attitudes, taste, and practices that provided the feeling of opposition without threatening the underlying structure. And you could grow your hair long, you could wear different clothes, you could listen to different music, you could take different drugs, practice spiritual techniques, and still fully participate in a consumer economy. And the people running the consumer economy noticed that. They started to sell the counterculture to itself, and the counterculture is a product to other people. who felt the guilt of not participating in the movement, but really didn't want to change. The sociologist Sam Binkley, in his study of the 1970s, Getting Loose, traced how this transformation occurred. The ethos of getting loose, of releasing the body from its discipline constraints, of breaking free from the uptight conformity of the 50s, was genuinely appealing to millions of Americans. It spoke to real needs, real deprivations, and a real.
real hunger for authentic experience. But getting loose was systematically stripped of its radical potential and repackaged as a lifestyle choice. The techniques that were supposed to liberate the self became commodities. Yoga was a fitness class. Meditation was a stress management technique. Encounter groups became the corporate team building exercises, and hundreds of corporate team building coaches came out of Eastland. This wasn't a conspiracy. It was the ordinary operation of market forces on cultural material. The youth invents the culture. to scandalize the older people. And then it becomes the dominant culture,
and they buy flattering imitations of their own lifestyle and rebellion. The culture industries are extraordinarily efficient at absorbing opposition, stripping of political content, and selling it back to the public at style. The fundamental structures remained untouched. The suburbs still isolated people,
the corporation still demanded conformity, and the economy still required endless consumption. But now you could buy a weekend workshop where you screamed and cried and did primal scream therapy to hug strangers, and then return on Monday to the same job, the same home, and the same fundamental arrangements. The void wasn't filled, it was decorated. And throughout all these transformations, actual therapy was happening. People were sitting in rooms with other people, trying to understand their suffering, trying to find paths forward.
So what did therapy look like? By the 1970s, the therapeutic landscape had become remarkably diverse. Psychodynamic therapy remained influential, that evolution of Freud based on people who were using attachment theory instead of sex. And though it evolved considerably from what Freud was doing, you know, do works of people like Heinz Cohut and Karen Hornay. You know, Cohut's self-psychology emphasized empathy, the need for self-object relationship that provided mirroring and validation.
And it was warmer and more relational in psychoanalysis. Object relations theory developed by figures in Britain like Melanie Klein and Donald Winnicott or Ronald Fairbain shaping American practice. And these theorists emphasized the internalized representations of early relationships and how these internal objects shape our experience of current relationships. Gestralt therapy is developed by Fritz Perils and refined by subsequent practitioners, offered genuine tools for working with awareness, with the body, and with unfinished emotional business. It emphasized a present moment experience of taking responsibility for one's choices,
completing interrupted cycles of action and feeling. And these were not merely fashionable ideas, they were clinical insights that were really helping people. And the family systems approach matured into multiple schools. Therapists like Murray Bowen, Virginia Seteer, and Salvador Mnuchin, recognized that individuals exist inrelationalable systems, began to use the language of cybernetics to understand emotions as a system. They began to depathologize symptoms,
seeing them as messages and indicators about the state of the family and what the real problems were. And this depathologized problems in the individual. And these were real contributions. They would influence millions of patients and thousands of therapists, but they remained marginal to the mainstream. And the institutions that trained therapists, the insurance companies that paid for treatment and the academic departments that granted credentials, these remained committed to paradigms that were easier to standardize, easier to measure, and easier to fit into the bureaucratic machinery of American health care. And more importantly, they were systems that could be taught to anyone,
not just a select group of people that might have capacity to view life or hold space in a certain way, because they were models that had if this, then that outputs. It didn't require self-work or emotional maturity in vast quantities on the part of the practitioner. After Vietnam, the American myth was changing. The war didn't just break the narrative of American exceptionalism, but it unleashed a massive unprecedented epidemic of trauma, schizophrenia, and drug addiction among returning veterans who found a society that completely refused to look at them. The map became split between two groups of aesthetics, people who defended the American Dream as exceptional and accurate, and then people who criticized the American Dream as flawed without offering any other sort of solution.
And this trauma epidemic, as people began to be aware of PTSD, began to be aware of, began to be aware of schizophrenia, began to be aware of the effects of drug abuse, as they saw it on the streets, collided with another massive structural failure, mass de-institutionalization. Under the guise of progressive reform and cost-cutting, the state began emptying the psychiatric hospitals, and this wasn't entirely a bad thing. People were being held against their will that easily could have lived alone because the society or the system or the family that had put them in the institution didn't want them there. The institution had too much power. People with severe mental illness were often incarcerated in horrific and abusive institutions,
and reform was needed, and the tragedy is that there were viable alternatives. Models like the assertive community treatment teams existed and had been proven effective. And the act model envisioned a system where a multidisciplinary team of social workers, nurses, and psychiatrists met the patient where they were, inside the community, providing a web of care that functioned as a counterweight to the government. It was administered by healers, not by a police officer or a bureaucratic, But America didn't choose the act model. It didn't fund the community clinic long after the 80s. And the dark, unforgivable truth of the last 60 years of psychiatric reform is that we didn't
actually cure the asylum. We just took the roof off and we decided to turn the entire section of major major American cities into what are essentially open-air asylums. The untreated, traumatized veterans and the addicted were left to wander the streets, managed only by the penal system and the brutal apathy of the market. And this is ultimately, this, terrifying shadow of American psychology that begins about this time, a system that optimizes the worried well in suburbs while it's structurally abandoning the broken to the concrete. Marshall McLuhan called television a cool medium, by which he meant something intuitive, not that it was emotionally distant, but it required participation to complete.
Unlike the hot medium of film, which provided high-definition images that overwhelmed the viewer, television's low-resolution picture demanded that the viewer's nervous system fill in the missing information. Watching television was participatory. It was not passive in the way that watching a movie was passive. Portland, straight ahead. If you want some friendly advice, a haircut and take a bat, you wouldn't get hassled so much.
Hope this ride helped you out. You have a nice day, huh? Because the new American dream of the suburbs was failing to provide many Americans with a larger sense of meaning, the nation had to find its psychological cohesion elsewhere. It founded in paranoia. America found numerous existential threats and identitarian projects, both internally and outside of the country. Soviets, the bomb, and communism, but also a hippie movement that was failing to integrate and rapidly succumbing to trauma and drugs, especially with the wave of returning.
Vietnam veterans with PTSD. News was reinventing the apocalypse every 10 years because the system demanded a perpetual state of emergency to justify its economic architecture. And the culture became addicted to that threat, both materially and existentially, because without the threat, it would have to look inward. It wasn't just the hippies that became reactionaries. In the hot tubs of Eastland, as the 1970s bled into the 1980s, the authentic self mutated into the Silicon Valley Randian hero.
the techno-libertarian Ein-Rand protagonist who believed that society itself was obsolete, that we should bulldoze all of the restraints that society placed on the individual to make room for the rise of Randian Ubermensch heroes. The 1950s and 60s had seen the resurrection of the cowboy as the American hero. But by the 1970s and 80s, the American hero myth began to mutate into the ruthless businessman. The evolution of television and its role in American life had profound implications for American consciousness. Television watching created a particular neurological state. Alert but not active, engaged but not thinking, present but not reflecting. The viewer was absorbed into the image
through pathos, not observing it from distance. The critical faculties required by print, the ability to stop, reread, question, compare, were suspended. Screen became what Theodore Adorno would call the ultimate tool of the culture industry, a mechanism of mass deception where standardized cultural goods replaced authentic science. psychological reflection. And the televised image stripped of its authentic presence, what Walter Benjamin termed aura, trained the viewer in a state of distracted reception. Three networks dominated American television from the 1940s through the 70s, accomplishing what, something that had never been done before, a unified field of consciousness, spanning a continental nation. And when 60
millions Americans watched the same program on the same evening, they were synchronizing in a way that no previous technology had enabled. But what kind of sharing was it? McCloughan noted that television was not primarily used to tell information or to convey stories. It conveyed itself. The medium was the message. What Americans were absorbing hour after hour was not the content of particular programs, but the form of television itself, the segmentation, the interruption, the rhythm of entertainment punctuated by advertising, the flow of drama, to comedy, to news, with no differentiation of cognitive mode. And the training was more significant than any particular ideology. The programs might have contained as just TV shows. Americans were learning to accept interruption as normal,
to tolerate fragmentation, to experience their own attention as a resource to be captured and sold. Television was not just a brainwashing device. You know, theorists like Theodore Aderno and Max Horkheimer, who had fled Nazi Germany for America, looked at this new mass media and they saw a terrifying trap. They called it the culture industry, and they pointed out correctly that the brutal economic tradeoff of television was that it turned human time and human attention into a raw commodity. Your relaxation was industrialized, and your eyeballs were harvested, quantified and sold to advertisers. But that didn't really affect the person doing the selling. They weren't being depleted of anything that they saw, and so it was fine. But while Adorno saw only mass deception, Walter Benjamin understood
something deeper about what happens when images are mechanically reproduced. Benjamin recognized that modern life is full of terrifying and alienating shocks, and that mass media, film and television, provide a safe and synchronized space for a fractured society to collectively process those shocks. And the atomized and isolated plastic oasis of the 1950 suburb, where the physical town had been bulldozed, television was the only community left. And when the old scripts of how to live, the village elders, the church, the extended family were stripped away, the screen provided a new type of script. Yet it was manufactured and it was
sponsored by soap companies, but it was necessarily a form of social training. It allowed you to feel. And while early programs like Father Knows Best and Leave It to Beaver established an idealized middle class paradigm to shield the psyche against the ideological terrors of the Cold War, the medium quickly expanded and the screen began to parade a vast array of archetypes right into the suburban living room. If you felt alienated, by the cheerful domestic servitude of the 1950s, anthology series like The Twilight Zone acted as a cultural subconscious, safely processing the shadow of profound anxiety, paranoia,
and the severe nerves that everyone was feeling. Television became the psychological architecture of the suburb. It also became the encounter point that most people would have with mental health or psychology itself. Shows like the Bob Newhart show in growing pains, often featured psychiatics. The therapeutic traditions that the human potential movement
had authored, required knowing yourself or sustained attention, discipline. And you had to stay with a feeling long enough to understand it. You had to want to know yourself. And you had to trace a pattern back through time. Television was training Americans in exact opposite habits. And so the dominant cultural force of the era clashed with the dominant psychological model. Television taught rapid switching, tolerance of contradiction,
the expectation of immediate emotional payoff, and the inability to sustain attention through difficulty. A culture formed by television would have trouble doing the kind of psychological work that insight-oriented therapy required. By the time that the cognitive behavioral revolution arrived in the late 1970s and 80s, the psychiatric and medical establishment used all of the New Age Hocum as an excuse to throw everything away that was developing during the human potential movement and keep it constantly relegated to the fringes of American Psych. To re-scientify therapy became their goal, and they orchestrated a massive purpose. Dr. Robert Spitzer and the architects of the DSM-3 drove psychiatry back towards a rigid medical model.
We talked about that in the history of the DSM series. And Aaron Beck's CBT shifted the focus entirely towards the measurable, mechanical, behaviors that a hard science had always wanted. By the time the show Dallas aired in 1980, America was coming to terms with, as commentator Matt Crisman points out, that its East-Cloast elites that had been the guiding old money were being replaced by, the new money of the Texas oil fields. And the spectacle on TV on the show Dallas, who shot J.R. Was this way that America grieved,
the shock of the death of JFK, and a kind of national encounter group, all alone in their living rooms, but all feeling the same thing collectively. The television had become psychotherapy, as the nation grieved and accepted the passing of the torch from one group of billionaires to the next,
and also the collective trauma of the uncertainty of the American dream. by obsessing about a shooting in Dallas for an entire year. One of the prominent critics of the era, Dr. George Engel, warned in 1977 that psychiatry was in crisis because it was leaning too heavily into a reductive biomedical paradigm. He argued for a biopsychosocial model, one that would later be adapted by social work in America, warning that stripping the human context from suffering would be disastrous. And the establishment ignored that warning, and the re-scientification of therapy was complete.
And the release of the DSM3 removed the subjective agency from psychiatrists and transferred it to the diagnostic checklists of a formula-based diagnostic manual. The American counterculture had been inhabiting the psychological academic spaces more so than any other academic discipline. However, they failed to make any sort of material change towards their own goals. And the human potential movement had inadvertently reinforced the very individualism that it claimed to transcend. end. Finding yourself became the project, and yourself could be found without challenging the institution, the architecture, or the economic arrangements that shaped life. Binkley's insight here is that the liberation of the self from traditional constraints, which felt radical, actually served the emerging economic order perfectly. The neoliberalism that was beginning to take shape
in the 1970s required exactly this kind of self, flexible, adaptable, and endlessly self-improving, consuming experiences as products. And the human potential movement taught people to feel liberated while remaining captured. It provided the aesthetic of freedom without the substance. And psychology, by focusing relentlessly on the individual, helped make this capture invisible. By the dawn of the 1980s, American culture had become a brutal filtering mechanism. The public was having a profound problem telling the difference between what was real and what could be sold. And the deeper, more holistic answers that therapy offered had failed to become a problem,
that American life could sell. During the material surplus of the 1980s, the nation simply did not have to look at the depths anymore. The depression wasn't happening. It wasn't wartime. The void was still there, but the culture had developed sophisticated mechanisms for not seeing it. And this mass cultural blindness perfectly set the stage for the cognitive behavioral therapy revolution. The 1970s ended with the groundwork laid for a very different kind of psychology. It would be standardized, manualized, medication focused, insurance compatible, and it would speak the language of evidence as science preferred it. But the ghost of this era still haunt psychology today. After the transformation to the techno-libertarians,
Silicon Valley never stopped trying to co-opt the human soul and take over psychology. But now they're doing it through new footing, large language models and algorithmic AIs. When you hear a Silicon Valley billionaire talk about fusing quantum physics and AI to create God through microchips and that this is resonating with your soul, or one of the things that they see. recognize this as the shadow legacy of something like Eastland's ideas being co-opted. Terrorers of the cybernetic movement are still with us, the ones that people like Marshall McLuhan began to see the implications of in 1960. Deep psychological connection on the internet is an illusion, administered by a machine
explicitly designed to extract and optimize your data. It's the same cybernetic trap but updated to the 21st century. The comfortable void is still sitting right in the middle of the living room. We haven't filled it. We've just built much more sophisticated screens so that we don't even see them anymore. More importantly, psychotherapy still struggles with an identity crisis wondering how much of a product it is, what its goals are, and how much it is able to butt heads with a contradicting culture or a technological paradigm of the time. One of the reasons for doing a series like this is that I don't see many of these problems as being new.
I see many of them as problems left by other generations and kick down the real. road for us now. Every 10 years, mainstream media will pretend that a mental health crisis is a sudden, mysterious modern phenomenon, but it's not. It's the exact same problem with no name that Breddy Ferdin diagnosed in 1963. Only now the surplus wealth is gone, and the American dream has been stripped for parts, and the safety net has been completely dissolved. The baby boomers refused to look at this void. They couldn't. They were too close to it. And they took Miletown and they watched sitcom patriarchs tell them that everything was fine. And Generation X tried to mock the void with irony, but they couldn't build anything to replace it. The millennials tried to
hack the void with side hustles, self-optimization, and something that felt more authentic than Best Buy and Appleby's by building breweries and hanging Edison classic light bulbs on the wall with extension cords, completely exhausting themselves in the process. And now Gen Z is coming in paralyzed by the weight of the next thing as they struggle to exist in the stream of technology and algorithmic consciousness as it currently exists. We're still inside the exact same architectural and psychological trap. We just happen to be the ones who are currently holding the bag. We're being forced to solve the terrifying structural collapse of the 1950s that was medicated, and the 1960s that tried to scream and self-indulge its way away. In the 1980s, it got buried under cognitive checklists and consumer
credit, but no solution was ever found. The alienation was never cured, and the open-air asylum's were never closed. The death of meaning was never addressed and the psychological architects of the 20th century just kept building better screens and prescribing better pills, and now better algorithms, deferring the collapse for one more decade and leaving us to navigate the ruins of their avoidance. And so the question persists, what is psychology's role in this process? Is it supposed to sit back and watch? Is it supposed to offer a solution? And how much is it supposed to diagnose the current culture that it operates within. These used to be questions that people sat around and encountered groups and tried to confront, and now they're just managing collapse,
managing a system that no one is trying to fix anymore. If this feels like endless looping, it may not be. It may be a patient repeating a pattern on a couch that it needs to recognize, and before it can change it, it must bring recognition and awareness to the pattern itself. Each generation genuinely believed that they were breaking the cycle. The hippies thought they were over-throwing the behaviorists. The cognitive therapist thought that they were curing the hippies, but they were all just running on the exact same wheel, and they were just upgrading the software of their own containment. And this is the ultimate tragedy of American psychology. It became the mechanism for endless deferral. It trained us to constantly optimize ourselves for a society that
was fundamentally broken rather than asking us to fix society itself, even while it was asking us to talk about fixing society. And now the loop is spinning faster, and we're not just to be. facing modern mental health crisis, we're now facing the accumulated compound interest of 80 years of deferred psychological debt. The system keeps looping, offering us mindfulness apps to cure our existential exhaustion, and AI language models to cure our profound isolation. It's the same deferral, just deliberate at fiber optic speed. Technologies that were created for connection have bred profound isolation, and psychology will continue to remain in this loop until it starts to confront that tension. And until we realize that we're trapped in this loop,
There is not a techno fix for this problem, and we can't self-actualize or compute our way out of the structural nightmare The ghost will remain in the machine and the void will keep waiting for us in the center of the living room A old film flicker on a cracked white wall Smoking in your father's coat Dust in the beam like a cheap disco History looping through your machines your Your soft set get carried through the tangled wires cold machines Warm ghosts you sing and something in me shakes
I'm holding on to everywhere we were not mistakes There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.